foreign
[Music]
well as you all know today is National
Hot Dog Day and perhaps you also know
that hot dog is my favorite meat I love
hot dogs I love them in buns I love them
outside of buns I love them with baked
beans I just like hot dogs it's the best
you know best meat there is without
question so to all of you who like me
are celebrating a national hot dog day
congratulations to you and may there be
many many more hot dogs served in our
wonderful land
hello people it is July 20th 2023 that's
right just one day after national hat
hot dog day I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report we are live streaming on
Rumble locals and YouTube if you'd like
to join us for a live chat during the
show with other actual human beings not
autonomous Bots and other weirdos uh
join us right now at
reubenreport.locals.com where of course
we have a uh post game show as well and
we are doing a Reuben report Community Q
a today after I get to a couple stories
up top we are going to analyze the
modern thought leaders of the Democrat
Party these are clever witty thoughtful
people
in Bizarro land but on this planet not
bright not good not nice and I don't
know why we have anything to do with any
of them but before we do anything else
yesterday was national hot dog day I did
not know that until I saw that very
viral video of Mitt Romney Walking The
Halls uh in DC telling us that it was
national hat Hot Dog Day I'd like to
play the video again because there's so
many things in this video that sort of
perfectly encapsulate why everyone hates
politicians and why I often said
throughout the years for as frustrated
as I may be with Donald Trump right now
that Donald Trump is far more authentic
than any of these people could we play
this thing again well as you all know
today is National Hot Dog Day and
perhaps you also know that hot dog is my
favorite meat I love Hot Dogs
in buns I love them outside of buns I
love them with baked beans
that's the best whatever the best meat
there is without question
maybe you're celebrating uh National Hot
Dog Day
congratulations to you and
congratulations for celebrating in our
wonderful National
like what you know that video that's
been going viral lately of this girl on
a plane where she apparently gets into a
fight with some guy in the back of the
plane and then they you see her kind of
going to the front she turns around and
she's like pointing at this guy that's
not a real human that's not a real human
like I'm really starting to think that
we played the video yesterday of John
Kerry as a lizard man you know the
tongue is constantly popping out of his
mouth and then Mitt Romney national hot
dog day it's like who are these people I
love Hot Dogs
we got a big show for you today we're
going to dive into uh that's a little
Republican lunacy right there because
the Republicans ain't much better uh
they're a little better but they ain't
much better we're going to dive into
mostly just like the General State of
insanity of the Democrat Party like
there's been so many things in the last
couple days and we've been mostly
focusing on the Republican primary stuff
so we're going to dive into that and as
I said a Community Q a uh real quick let
me talk to you guys about Route 66 you
know last week I shared a story about
the iconic
Route 66 Highway that stretches across
the U.S from Chicago to L.A I also
shared some of the challenges for
survival that many of the small
businesses have been confronted with
since since the construction of the U.S
Interstate freeway system although more
efficient the interstate design bypasses
many of the once thriving shops
scattered along the Mother Road and has
nearly driven them into Extinction
reintroducing one of our newest sponsors
Route 66 revitalization that's what I'm
doing right now this is a non-profit
organization that was created to bring
awareness to the Forgotten businesses
still trying to survive along the old
Route 66 Corridor and ultimately
preserve the Nostalgia of the little
shops and restaurants that represent a
booming time in America's past yeah we
used to have a booming America pretty
good one of the current projects that
the Route 66 revitalization team is
working on is to revitalize the
California Route 66 Museum located in
Victorville California halfway between
LA and Vegas this American treasure
nearly closed several times over the
years however the Museum's dedicated
volunteers began paying for operating
expenses out of pocket to keep the doors
open and amazingly it's still free to
the public in an effort to draw more
awareness and tourism to the museum the
Route 66 revitalization team Acquired
and donated a historic 1968 Santa Fe
Railroad caboose and are in the process
of relocating the train car to be set
adjacent to the museum to create a new
Buzz at new traffic hoping to complete
the Caboose relocation project this week
the Route 66 revitalization team is
asking for your support to help you can
send donations through their secure
website at
www.route66revitalization.com or you can
access the donation Page by taking a
picture of the QR code below with your
phone you can also make donations
directly to historic Route 66 Museum
at info at CA
route66museum.com it is a worthy cause
and now back to me okay let's dive into
the Democrats and when you think about
the Democrats you think of the aocs the
ilhan Omars the Rashida to leaves the
Gavin newsoms the Gretchen whitmers it
is a clown car of just nonsensical
stupidity horrible people and usually
botched face work but AOC particularly
she's she's just the queen of all of the
nonsense and she's very upset that
occasionally people say mean things to
her on the Twitter she tweeted this out
about the Twitter
I have never experienced more harassment
on this platform than I do now
people now pay to give their harassment
more visibility the de-verification
process the de verification of
journalists Civic organizations and
figures has made it impossible to follow
conversations I wish it could be usable
again and she's responding to a Twitter
safety tweet right there now there's
just so much hilarity here because one
of the things that Twitter did that Elon
did that I personally was a little
frustrated by it at first but I now
realize why it was so good is that he
democratized that blue check process
right so the old way you could get the
blue check and if you add the blue check
for those of you that are not on Twitter
and as I often say there's just no need
to be on there if you haven't made it on
there at this point God bless you keep
going keep going go forward but the blue
check was the signifier that you were
actually you right so that if I Dave
Rubin had the blue check for Reuben
report people would know that I was the
authentic Dave Rubin because they were a
gajillion other fake Dave Rubens just
like they're a Jillian other fake aocs
and fake uh Elon musk's and everything
else what he did was he said oh now you
can actually pay for the blue check
which will will verify that you're a
real person you're not a bot you're not
a computer and everything else and what
that allowed for Not only was for him as
a businessman to make a little money on
that 44 billion dollar investment but it
also allowed more people to to feel like
they were had a little skin in the game
because the verification process was
basically if you were a huff post
journalist or you worked at CNN or any
of these activist organizations you got
the blue check it somehow made you and
your opinions more valuable than
everybody else and one thing that
Democrats hate and progressives really
hate is they hate being thought of as
everybody else she's pissed that her
blue check is the same blue check that
everybody else has I now realize that
it's completely fine people know who I
am it is what it is and now people throw
in a couple bucks and then because of
the blue check you might see their
comments more just broadly speaking
without all right then enough of The
Insider Twitter stuff
the idea that you pay to be part of
something so that your voice can be
heard actually elevates the conversation
right when everything is free nothing
has any value and that's one of the
problems with the internet people have a
million burner accounts you can sign up
anonymously for everything you control
people all day long and also her
complaining that people say mean things
to her people say mean things to me all
day long you don't have to open the app
you don't have to respond to people you
can block and mute people all of those
things but victimhood we know hierarchy
right it's triangle like this victimhood
at the top Elon did respond to her and
he said me thinks somebody doth protest
too much of course but let's continue
with AOC because her eye is on the ball
you know there's that Meme of her eyes
kind of going in every which direction
but her eyes are on the ball
she wants us to focus on climate change
because AOC and her Green New Deal can
save you and that's what we should be
focusing on focusing on rather than I
don't know massive government corruption
and scandals involving the president of
the United States
if Republicans truly want to get to the
fact here and they want to understand
why Mr Weiss decided to charge Hunter
Biden the way he did let's hear from Mr
Weiss
but until then we must move on
from these theories and focus on the
issues that matter to the American
people like ending the scourge of gun
violence that is plaguing our country
confronting and combating the climate
crisis and standing up for our
constitutional rights and yes going
after the enormous amount of inequity
and Injustice in our tax system and with
that I yield back to the chair
oh for the love of God first off they
really just don't want you having any
knowledge as to what was going on with
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden and the Deep
corruption at barisma and the Energy
company and all of that right because if
you looked at any of that on top of just
all of the porn pictures and the smoking
crack and all that stuff you might
uncover that the Democrats are deeply
corrupt and that Joe Biden is in bed
with a whole bunch of bad people and all
of that I know you guys get it but then
the way she says well you know in
essence we can't do two things at once
because she really wants you to focus on
the climate as if just imagine the idea
that AOC or John Kerry or any of these
climate hoes could do anything to fix
the climate they cannot they just cannot
even if you think that the climate is
changing and you believe that it's
man-made climate change and you think we
got to get rid of fossil fuels and
everything else if you think that AOC
can fix it you're just nuts uh she also
focused on
do you think that puzzle fuel CEO should
decide whether the planet gets set on
fire
you're freaking me out man
um you know the other thing there is
she's also once wants to focus on ending
gun violence of course she never talks
about say a place like Chicago can I get
the numbers Brock can you get me the
numbers how many people were shot in
Chicago this past weekend she never
talks about how the places that have the
most gun regulation are often the places
that the most people are shot and killed
there are many reasons for that
generally speaking good guys don't
randomly shoot people so they never want
you to think about that when she talks
about gun regulation what she means is
we want to take guns away from as many
law-abiding citizens as possible so that
the government us we will have all of
the guns I'm getting the gun numbers on
the Fly how many people wow
I am absolutely shocked there were only
13 people shot in Chicago this weekend
13 people and only one person was killed
in Chicago by gun violence this weekend
we should probably just end the show and
go celebrate you guys want to go to
where do you want to go you want to go
to uh Dave and Buster's or something
like let's just let's go shoot some
aliens and eat some wings and that is
I'm shocked I'm absolutely shocked
anyway you get it they just want your
eye off the ball they don't want you to
look at government corruption they don't
want you to look at how they've mucked
up the economy they don't you look at
how they've screwed up the Border or
what they're doing in Ukraine if they
want you to focus on things that you
cannot control that they certainly
cannot control and everything else watch
this one here's the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and Joe good
old Joe Scarborough he's very you know
it's hot it's you're not gonna believe
this it's hot right now in certain parts
of America we're rolling into August
we're at the end of July that's known uh
I'm not a scientist but I believe we
call that summer it's one of the Four
Seasons I'm not talking about Frankie
Valli in the Four Seasons I'm talking
about the actual Four Seasons uh and
it's hot right now and Joe's freaking
out because it's warm and we we're holy
Jesus it's warm
way I mean it's getting harder and
harder to fly this summer really tough
because of of of of of the extraordinary
uh weather crisis that is gripping the
country uh causing flights to be
canceled left and right uh headline out
of Las Vegas Delta flight canceled when
heat related illnesses hey passengers
headed from Las Vegas to Atlanta
108 degrees outside four hours on the
tarmac and people inside the airplane
suffering uh heat related illnesses
um it is again I mean and you you look
at the storms you look at the disasters
and if you're if if you're still denying
the impact of climate change and the
impact of billions and billions of
Americans uh pumping uh carbon into the
atmosphere non-stop China and India
especially right now but also the United
States disproportionately doing the same
you're you're you're you're living in an
alternate reality you really yes Joe I
am living in an alternate reality than
you because you live in Bizarro
Progressive cycle land and I live on
planet Earth everything you just said
there of course everything you just said
was completely nonsense it's hot let me
get this straight it's hot in Las Vegas
at the end of July it got into the
hundreds in Vegas in the end of July the
plane that he's referring to uh is
because the air conditioning broke on
the plane that does happen on planes
every now and again I'm guaranteeing
almost everybody watching this has been
on a plane where they've had an air
conditioning problem it does happen
every now and again and people are
saying it's very hot in Arizona right
now that's been a thing it's very hot in
Arizona uh Connor you are from Phoenix
can you tell me as a as an arizonan
growing up there you're a young kid
you're out there on your bike in the
summer but how would you describe the
weather I mean this is you know you're
in your 30s so this is while ago
you don't go Outdoors he's saying it's
warm it was warm when he was a child
growing up in the summer in Arizona do
you understand this and that this Joe
and you billions of Americans with your
carbon and your fossil fuels and it's
like all of us could shut down all of
our cars and our gas stoves and we could
sit underground eating goo and China and
India would actually still be pumping
all that crap into the into the
atmosphere that's how it works people
but thank God we have Democrats because
Democrats will save you from heat they
will they will do everything they
possibly can here is a woman who has
more artificial injections in her face
than almost anyone in public life short
of Madonna yes that's right Nancy Pelosi
hide the children but she's doing it for
the children she's fighting the climate
for the children
elections have ramifications on uh
happily in a place where I can
continue to be working politically but I
would hope that it could be we could be
working in a unifying way to bring
people together Democrats Republicans
declines to State as we call them in
California so that we're there to honor
our oath to uphold the law no one is
above it and to be respectful of women
because that again is really important
for our country I'm there for the
children and so my judgment about
anybody is what what they are doing is
harmful to the children whether it's the
air they breathe the climate crisis that
we have their education children
learning parents earning we have a a
wonderful country and we have to
recapture some of the the greatness that
again has
put it been put in doubt by uh the
current leadership in the Republican
Party in the Congress of the United
States the children our children our
children
that's the Crypt Keeper they're doing
this stuff on the Fly With Me people
he freaks me out like that woman imagine
you're a small child Nancy police
evening you wake up you see Nancy
Pelosi's face you're gonna freak the F
out nobody should ever have to see Nancy
but especially without makeup can you
imagine what she looks like but look
guys
she's doing this for the children and at
the end where she blames all of the
problems they're actually the price
because of the Republicans the
Republicans are not in charge of the
Senate the Republicans are not in charge
of the White House but it's those mean
Republicans making the Earth hot it's
hot somebody do something oh my God but
thank God it's not not only do we have
AOC great gal we've got Pelosi we've got
good Guardians Of Truth like Joe and his
sidekick over there whatever her name is
Mika we've also got John Kerry and he's
out there he's flying in the plane all
over the place and he's telling
everybody they've got to stop doing
stuff that he does here he is and he had
a conversation with the vice president
of yeah look at this I had a
constructive conversation with vice
president Han Zhang this is the vice
president of China today about the
climate crisis a universal threat to
humankind and imperative of the U.S and
China to work together to address it of
course John Kerry is really just going
around begging people to do what he
wants here he is at a press conference
chatting about climate change with the
Chinese and he just really wants them to
do something but guess what guys
China's going to do whatever the hell it
wants
China and the United States are the two
most powerful economies in the world
we also have to admit the two largest
emitters of greenhouse gases
and so the imperative of our two
countries coming together and working
and showing the rest of the world how we
can cooperate and begin to address this
with the urgency is required guys he's
very very concerned about the climate
and he flies
all over the world to tell everybody how
they should live and what they should do
and you know damn well the guy's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars because
he married into the Heinz Family yes the
Heinz Ketchup family his wife is Teresa
Heinz Kerry okay uh
but
it's very important that you don't do
certain things like use your gas stove
right that's very important and he's
going to fly private all the time we
showed you a poor a portion of this
yesterday I have to show it again it's
just so spectacular he's testifying at
Congress and they're asking about his
private plane and watch this weasel
operate and I'm pretty sure this counts
as lying under oath and I know nobody
gets punished for any of these things
but here we go
so uh I just don't agree with your facts
which began with the presentation of one
of the most outrageously persistent lies
that I hear which is this private jet we
don't own a private jet I don't own a
private jet I personally have never
owned a private jet and obviously it's
pretty stupid to talk about coming in a
private jet from the state department up
here
just honestly if that's where you want
to go go there a few moments later you
uh just testified under oath that you
never owned a private jet Mr chairman
I'd like to enter into the record uh
article here from February 15th of 2000
2023 the John Kerry family private jet
was sold shortly after accusations of
climate hypocrisy Mr secretary you stand
by that testimony that you've never
owned or I personally family personally
yes my wife owned a plan
[Music]
the gall of that man is just incredible
he personally never now earlier in that
video that we just showed you there he
kept saying we but then at the end I
personally oh yeah oh I completely
forgot I forgot that my wife did own a
plane
that I was always flying on that plane I
had no freaking idea it's just
incredible they lie about everything
next tweet this is ilhan Omar noted
racist Socialist Communist awful human
being the Earth just broke the record
for the hottest day in a hundred twenty
thousand years in fact we broke in fact
we broke in on three separate days
National Climate emergency now and of
course this was fact checked by Twitter
the community notes thing which is just
spectacular the source for this claim
appears to be the University of Maine
climate reanalyzer which has added a
recent notice making it clear that it
should not be taken as an official as
official observation records because the
real records on this stuff really only
go back to like the late 1800s if we're
to believe any of this stuff the idea
that ilhan Omar has any sense of what
was going on temperature wise on Earth
120 000 years ago is completely
absolutely completely insane but can you
put the Tweet up one more time because
what really forget all the lies I get it
you guys get it like they lie about
absolutely everything and it's all just
done as a farce to Keep Your Eye Off the
Ball as I said earlier the last line is
the is the key part of this she just
says a whole bunch of nonsense but why
does she say it to get us to a National
Climate emergency now and you know
what'll happen guys we will have
National Climate emergency lockdowns and
eventually they'll tell you you can only
be outside for a certain amount of time
and you'll only be able to eat these
things because they're gonna have to
close an awful lot of farms because
those cows you guys like eating meat you
like that rib eye but those cows are
farting and those cow farts are doing
something to the environment but do not
worry they will be eating well
oh terrible people and speaking to
terrible people here is cringe
Jean-Pierre uh she was doing one of her
little press secretary things that she
pretends to do over there at the White
House and uh that she was asked because
Biden himself Joe Biden himself a tweet
that he put out now obviously Joe Biden
is not allowed to hold a phone he
probably doesn't even know what Twitter
is you know they're just somebody else
is doing it but Joe Biden's Twitter
account put out a tweet that was fact
checked by Twitter and cringe was asked
about it the president had a tweet out
last night saying that real wages for
the average American worker have are
higher than they were before the the
pandemic that tweet has now been
annotated with um a message from the
platform saying that that is not factual
and they have some some some stats and
some charts uh footnoted along with that
do you welcome that um kind of
contestation from Tech platforms do you
disagree
do you have any any well we disagree
because if we're looking at the data
from uh from February of 2021 and what
we've seen is that wages have have
gotten stronger have increased we've
seen that by neck economic binomics uh
has been really helpful in getting to
make sure that we build an economy that
leaves the one behind well we just
disagree with the backtrackers we just
make up numbers sort of like we do
something called the inflation reduction
act which actually just means we print a
whole bunch of money uh which actually
causes inflation but we put reduction
right in the title of it so you don't
really have to think about it do you
which really just gets us to the uh the
nice linchpin of everything that I've
done for the first 20 minutes of today's
program a simple line by Joe Biden when
he was campaigning when he actually did
tell the truth
we choose Unity over
to choose science over fiction we choose
truth over
so we're living in a society
we choose truth over facts we choose
truth over facts they make up something
that's true and they choose it over
facts I do accept that guys let me tell
you a little bit more about Route 66 and
then we'll get to the Community Q a but
before I do let me sip a little coffee
out of this beautiful Route 66 mug that
based on me
that is a fine two-tone mug right there
that's very nice uh guys I mentioned the
amazing work that the Route 66
revitalization group is doing to help
the mom-and-pop businesses scattered
along the old mother Road your donations
are for an amazing cause and will help
Route 66 revitalization team continue
their mission to help preserve the
Priceless gems along the Route 66 mother
road again to offer your help you can
send donations through their secure
website at
www.route66revitalization.com or you can
access the donation Page by taking a
picture of that queue it's there the QR
code right there you can take a picture
of it it'll pop up on your phone and now
back to me all right let's get to a
little Rubin report dot locals.com
Community Q a and by the way since we
have the live chat going during the show
why don't we do this Phoenix today we
will throw in a bonus question at the
end on the fly from someone during the
program right now gamma says we have
created a generation that considers any
form of discomfort or inconvenience
traumatic which means that literally all
jobs are toxic work environments Dave is
there a way to reverse this destructive
cultural malaise right at the point
where we're at right now anything can
offend anybody and that means you're in
a toxic work environment and that means
you've got to talk to the Department of
this and that and the human resources
people better do this and oh my God a
white person said that to me and a
straight woman did that it it is
demolishing everything that's what
people really need to understand like
you can joke about it
or dismiss this woke stuff or go okay a
bunch of kids with blue hair are
screaming about something but those
people with those brainwashed terrible
ideas related to collectivism and racism
and all of these things they start
moving up in the world right and I think
a lot of people this was this was a big
thing on my show for those of you that
have been watching us you know really
since probably
2016-17 when I first started talking
about what was happening with the modern
left and I was always using the phrase
regressive left right that became a meme
in and of itself because I said it so
often
um one of the things that people would
always say to me was Dave Dave these
kids are just college kids and when they
get out in the real world like the real
world will show them what's up like then
they'll wake up they'll be smacked with
reality and you know that'll scare them
straight and what we found out was that
the real world folded like a wet paper
bag in essence right these people then
became uh department heads in HR
departments they became people that were
pushing die look what they've done to
Disney look what they've done to Bud
Light look what they've done to Target
look what they've done to look at the
people that now are government officials
in states and cities like Los Angeles
where you now can steal 850 worth of
stuff but if you steal 900 you're in
trouble which is why I always say you're
allowed to steal a PlayStation 5 in
about five games but if you steal that
six game you take uh give me a game give
me a game
Madden come on I could have done that I
was going for something like with a gun
or something if you take too many of
those then you're in trouble it's all
nonsense and it destroys everything and
we must fight it and not hire these
people it really is as simple as that if
you're if you're someone uh own a
business or you're in a position of
hiring you really have to make sure to
discriminate and I really mean that uh
discrimination to some extent is not a
bad thing you don't want to discriminate
based on the on an immutable
characteristic but you should
discriminate on someone's idea set and
you do not want to bring any of these
people into your organization by the way
whether that's your uh whether it's
where you work whether it's your
religious institution the school that
you send your kids to or anything else
Arnie says have you ever wished you were
born a different species
oh that's interesting uh I mean when I
was a kid I wanted to be a Jedi that's
not a different species per se
um I'll tell you I'll tell you I haven't
lived here in Florida right now
um I you know the lizards are doing
pretty well out here we we have so many
freaking lizards here I've showed you a
couple pictures of these massive you
know six seven foot iguanas that they're
fighting with but they're they're
hanging out they lay in the sun all day
they're just enjoying life breathing
slowly calmly eating every now and again
they all around my pool which that
we're working on that that's a problem
but they're living a pretty solid life
so I don't think I've ever thought of
myself as uh really cared to be another
species I guess a canonical asexual
perhaps would that be a different
species Daddy I want to see a movie with
if you don't know what I'm talking about
Watch yesterday's show Jay says instead
of confuse the cat we might play confuse
the woke question if we divide 123
genders by white supremacy how much
climate change do we have answer it
depends on how many Teslas musk sells
this is the level of stupidity we are
getting to right now like it really like
those types of questions and the
nonsense
look everything I just showed you from
AOC like it's all just drivel with these
people and again you've just got to mock
them into Oblivion cine says did you
ever think of doing a carnivore diet
like Jordan Peterson
um you know I've never done it strict
like Jordan as I've told you guys before
he's he's actually I don't know how much
he's saying about it publicly but I know
he's diversifying his diet a little bit
right now I think he's mentioned that
publicly but for years because of a
bunch of autoimmune issues he had and
health problems
and some stuff related to depression and
a whole bunch of other things he did the
complete Elimination Diet literally when
we were on tour he would have a rib eye
for breakfast he would have a rib eye
for lunch he would get a tomahawk that
probably could feed four people for
dinner steak I'm talking about medium he
would always get a medium and with just
a tiny bit of salt no nothing no oil no
pepper no nothing no sides no greens
nothing no potato and he would get that
big ass Tomahawk and then he would have
that in a bag snacking on throughout the
day because he couldn't eat the tomahawk
for four so I ate a crazy crazy amount
of red meat when I was with him but I
usually was doing something green on the
side or occasionally some potatoes or
something and sometimes obviously I
didn't get steak I mean we have we have
a pretty good
dietary situation around here we try to
do lean proteins we do a lot of red meat
we did lamb last night but with just
vegetable and maybe some like simple
rice or simple potato and I'm trying to
drink a lot of water and stay hydrated
rated because it's hot here in the
summer in Florida somebody alert the
climate people
um but no I never thought about doing it
so specifically fortunately right now I
don't have any like major health
problems or autoimmune issues or
anything like that to do something so
severe as uh as the Elimination Diet but
it worked for Jordan it really didn't
and it might work for you Bonnie says
I've heard a lot of commentators say
that Ron DeSantis doesn't have the
Charisma or wit that Trump has I think
he should lean into that we're not
looking for a comedian or who is the
best at sarcasm and witty comebacks we
need someone who has the policies the
cajones great word and can actually do
what is best for America your thoughts I
totally agree with you I totally agree
with you in that what I am looking for
from a president are the two questions
that I keep bringing up lately right do
I roughly agree with the stuff that you
believe in are we just are we
ballparkented enough doesn't have to be
everything but is it ballparked enough
that I agree with you and then the
second question which is the more
important one do you think this person
can accomplish those things DeSantis for
me question one yes question two
absolutely right but we should
acknowledge that that's not what
everybody is looking for right A lot of
people want the show a lot of people
want the reality version of all of this
that Donald Trump offers a lot of people
want the owning and the destruction and
the memes and blah blah blah so you need
to do both I would say I agree with you
on this
the scientist does have to lean into who
he is you know I've been with him and he
can be fun and as I said when when we've
done one-on-one things talking about
baseball or like just asking me things
about the show or what it's been like to
move to Florida like stuff like that
um he's not the funniest guy on the
planet but I have seen him crack jokes
uh I've seen him be a really good father
with his daughters when we had lunch a
couple weeks ago in Nevada like I think
he can lean into that a little bit I
think he's what I think people are
seeing with him is he's so hyper
competent that in some ways they're
using that against him and I think that
that's a really dangerous play I agree
it's like do you want a comedian or a
president do you want a friend or a
president do you want a dad or a
president
I want a competent president but I think
they will have to do something around
some of that and by the way I think
they're already doing it you know he uh
he just went on Russell Brand which did
they release that yet I spoke to Russell
yesterday I'm not sure if they released
it yet but Russell told me he really
really liked him and they got into some
fun stuff actually what Russell told me
was that he wanted to get into more of
that and they got and they ran out of
time but do Russell Brand do Rogan as I
said get up there fight with the ladies
of you let people see you in a little
bit of a different way you obviously
wear t-shirts on the weekend let's see
some of that and loosen it up a little
bit but again patience guys we're seven
months away from the first primary uh
Lauren says since you're departing our
presence soon I would like to hear
beforehand your wisdom for us to strive
and our own hopes for the future in
terms of your faith perspective so
that's right guys I cannot believe it I
said to David last night I cannot
believe it is almost August this year
and as I've said to you guys before
maybe it's partly having kids maybe it's
partly being in my mid-40s or something
this year maybe it's partly that life
has been good I love Florida and what
I'm doing for a living and all those
things but this year has gone by so
freaking fast it's just incredible to me
that we're about to hit our August Off
the Grid situation uh our last show
actually what's the date on that the
27th right so our last show actually
will be a week from today next Thursday
uh the 27th I got to take care of
something on the 28th and it's an
abbreviated
off the great August because our last
show July 27th then I go off the grid
but I will be back in Milwaukee
on August 23rd where the first
Republican debate will be we just Rumble
is the exclusive live streamer I've
mentioned it YouTube's not getting it so
it'll be on Fox Television live streamed
on Rumble Rumble is going all in
spending a ton of money building great
Studios my on the grid show will be 11
A.M in the morning and then we'll do
some post game and pre-game stuff we've
got uh we've got a couple of the
presidential candidates who've already
committed to join me on stage we're
gonna have a live audience it's going to
be awesome we're figuring all that out
but to the specifics of your question uh
in terms of spirituality and everything
else look I said it years ago and it
pissed off a lot of people when I came
back from one of the August and I said
you know I I cannot consider myself an
atheist anymore one of the reasons that
I I do the Off the Grid thing is that
all of us whether you kind of do what I
do for a living or whatever you do
whether you're a ditch Digger or a
teacher or an artist or a physicist
all of us can be in on what we're doing
all the time and we're parents and we're
co-workers and colleagues and all those
things you could be in it all the time
all the time and what I realized years
ago from being in it all the time and
having to you know be on this thing an
awful lot and everything else I thought
I think this is this is going to be my
seventh year doing it but let me just
see if I can do it but could I really
just put this thing down and live like
people lived back in say 1982 could I do
it and it was kind of fun and then I did
it again and again and each year I
started gaining more perspective one of
the coolest things about it is and this
has happened to David as well he because
he mostly does it now with kids
obviously it's going to be a little bit
different this year
um is I have found that literally old
songs just start playing in my head and
I can remember every freaking word of
old songs I start out of nowhere like
two weeks in I'm thinking about a friend
in third grade who I haven't thought of
in 20 years ago like like some stuff
there's so much stuff in all of our
brains that we we are so cluttered with
nonsense that we can't get to but it's
all there and it gives me a month to
reorder everything and then come back
with fresh eyes and I think that that is
the that is the at a very kind of
literal level I think that is the
spiritual kind of uh move that I was
looking for throughout this so I cannot
wait and I hope you guys will try it you
know even just try it on the weekends uh
we're gonna put some content up when
we're off but maybe do it for a couple
days see how you can make it work and
and August is a good time to do that
Shelley says Dave how did you meet your
Reuben Report Team Connor Brock Daphne I
probably missed a few names if I did
forgive me it's apparent that you all
have different personalities that blend
together in amazing outcome of
friendship and respect look at us guys
we're like the the hobbits you know what
I mean we're like the hobbits how did I
meet these guys well let's see Connor's
Conor's my you're the OG at this point
Connor has been with me the longest at
this point and it was a couple I don't
know it was three four years back and uh
we were looking for a new director uh
things were changing uh during covid and
all that and we got an email from this
guy in Seattle and I said don't hold it
against him and it turned out you lived
what like a block away from chop it was
during that semi-autonomous zone where
the crazy messed up racists had their
own like four blocks in Seattle and I
was like this guy's interesting to me
let's see what happens and we did one
zoom and we liked him and then we did an
in-person thing and and it's been great
so he's
oh look at you kitty and Connor's
running the board right now so he gave
himself a round of applause that's nice
uh let's see who's been with me next
song is that that would be you Phoenix
Phoenix was originally uh my intern from
four or five years ago also something
like that and I offered Phoenix a job he
was like no I wanna I wanna stick
through and try to go to college and see
what happens and I was like I don't know
what you're doing but okay and then one
day uh he came to me he said Dave I
tried the college thing but if that
offer still stands I'd love to I'd love
to be part of the team I think we hired
you maybe maybe literally that day and
uh and then obviously both these guys
moved out to Florida with us uh Daphne
has been with us even long Barack you
were you were a young fresh uh face in
this thing Daphne I met at she was at
prageru before all of this and I was
doing my last prageru I think it was my
last prageru four minute video right and
uh Michael who was my previous producer
before Phoenix Michael knew Lou Daphne
and we were chatting a little bit
and the funny thing about prageru they
have a million employees there there are
like hundreds of people everywhere
everyone saying hi to me and you know
people more people know me than I know
them so everyone says hi blah blah blah
but I do remember walking down a hallway
with Daphne and she was very sweet and
friendly and offering to help however
she could and then I think maybe three
or four days later Helen who was my
previous assistant who I absolutely
adored and Helen she still watches the
show so shout out to Helen
um she uh she had some family stuff and
decided to go in a different direction
and then uh
two weeks later Daphne was on board and
then back there we have been uh got a
special guest today Michaela our current
intern who lives in Pittsburgh she is
here uh this week because we're doing
the big Reuben report Community Meetup
next week so uh next Thursday which will
be my last day on the grid that night
we're doing a locals Community Meetup in
Miami so if you want to join us and have
some drinks and food and all that good
stuff you can join us for that so
Michaela came to town to join that and
Michaela I think was just watching the
show and we were looking for an intern
and uh oh and yeah I Skyped with a
couple people she was by far the best
and uh here we are and then we've of
course got Chris who is in an
undisclosed location he does a lot of
the back end stuff on YouTube and Chris
actually I'm sorry Chris has been with
us for the longest even even Beyond you
Connor Chris I apologize you have been
with us for the longest and Chris is an
absolute All-Star uh so much of our
Channel growth and and how you guys get
the videos and everything else and then
finally Brock has been with what Brock
you've been with us longer than Michaela
but Brock uh only in the last how long
now about
December of last year we were looking
for a new social media guy uh marketing
guy I interviewed a couple people uh
Brock's all his like the resume and
everything was just absolutely perfect
and he used to work for the Chicago
Bulls and Toronto uh for Turning Point
USA and between basketball and just
getting the space and like he's a master
and he said I said he said Dave you know
you got to get the tick tock and I said
I'm not putting Chinese spyware on my
phone and he said Dave I'll do it for
you so he has the Chinese spyware on his
phone
to work for me and I thought what a good
man that's the longest answer I've ever
given for a q a let's keep moving
Eurasian says uh so leftists like
l-a-d-a George gascon think no one under
18 should ever be tried as an adult no
matter how serious the crime because the
science says human brains are not fully
mature enough to make rational decisions
until around age 25 but leftists also
think eight-year-olds should be able to
decide if they should have their junk
cut off do you think this hypocrisy
reveals some other agenda is at hand
well I think it does I think it does I
don't think that exposing their
hypocrisy ever wakes them up you know on
the margins you can get somebody here
and there but they don't seem to ever
respond to hypocrisy that's why I keep
showing you that video of Dick Levine
Richard Levine who lived his life as a
man into his 50s had two children then
he transitions whatever that means and
it's unclear what he did with his
genitals and frankly I don't want to
know
um and now he's for transitioning young
kids despite the fact that he says his
greatest joy in life was having those
children I I honestly it's it's hard to
think of something much more evil than
that you say that you are the greatest
joy in your life is that you did not
transition so that you could have these
children and now you do not
you do not want to keep well you want to
basically allow for kids to just be able
to do whatever the hell they want uh I'm
being we're correcting the record on the
Fly here oh I'm getting actual dates
people may want to know the actual dates
that the team joined us Chris has been
with me since May of 2019. let me tell
you something else great about Chris
what Chris did Chris emailed us and he
said hey I've been watching your show
for a while and I see what you guys are
doing on YouTube and all that and I'm a
YouTube optimization guy I deal with all
the back end stuff he said let me work
for you for I think I'm right about this
let me work for you for a month for free
let me just do some stuff for you and
you let me know if it works out and not
only did it work out but every month now
we Crush our numbers virtually every
month across the board watch time views
individual viewers monetization like the
whole thing so Chris has been with me
since May of 19. Phoenix has been with
me since May of 20. so you were my
intern before before Conor I stand
corrected holy cow uh Connor has been
with me since I've October of 2020
Daphne since May of 22 Brock since
December of 22 and Michaela since March
of 23. okay very good uh and Connor is
not taking back his Applause that he
gave himself so that's good Daisy says
did the Reuben report cookbook drop and
did I miss it no it has not dropped yet
it is completely my fault Daphne has
taken care of this I've got it sitting
on my desk printed out and I just need
to take one last look at it I promise
you you have my official word the Reuben
report Community cookbook which is some
recipes for me and the team and also
really from you guys the viewers that
will be posted in locals next week I
promise you I promise you Christine says
name A Life Lesson and leaving
California doesn't count ooh I mean
that's you know move to a place where
you're free that's like Dave Rubin 101.
um
I'll give you a life lesson I'll be
corny for just a moment
um I can tell you that in the almost
year now uh because Justin's almost one
there'll be one on August 6th uh of
being a father and not just a father for
for one kid but two it has completely
changed my life at every possible level
realizing fully not even realizing
because intellectually everyone knows it
but like having everything not be about
you waking up to these eyes that see the
world in the most open decent way and
look at you with nothing but pure joy
and knowing that it's your job to
hopefully fill them up with all of the
right stuff so they have a chance out
there in that brutal world like it does
something to you it does saying to you
I'll tell you uh one that was uh kind of
scary but put some things in perspective
about two months ago uh Luke wasn't
feeling well and and was kind of
vomiting a bit and it was it was late
night and then suddenly went very pale
so we were very concerned obviously and
we took him to the um to the Children's
Hospital that's near us and I don't know
it's about a 10 minute drive but as we
were going there and thankfully by the
time we even got into the car he started
to get some color back and it actually
turned out he was totally fine that's
that's a sidebar but as we were in the
car like I was like I was talking to God
I was literally like take me you can
take me instead of this kid take me
instead of this kid that is like a
deeply powerful thing
I I just got to know this kid and I'm
willing to throw my life on the line for
him like that's something that you can't
really explain until you're a parent so
I would say become a parent it's a good
one uh Eliza says I think it was a
brilliant decision to have your children
so close in age I get it except for
having twins most people cannot space
their children so close in age but I'm
curious if you have thoughts on the pros
and cons of having children so close in
age well the pros are obvious like these
kids have a they can play with each
other now and especially Luke has had a
nice little spurt a little growth spurt
now because two months is a lot when
they're very young where now they're
like pretty even and now finally Luke's
crawling around more so Luke So Justin's
not just like crushing him at all the
time so now they're really playing and
they're cracking each other up and like
I can set them up and get some blocks
out and like we can kind of do our thing
and that's just great I would say the
challenge of it
is there's two kids that you gotta feed
all the time there's two kids that you
gotta get to sleep all the time and take
naps and all of that stuff and it's just
you're just double you know you're
doubling the fun and you're also
doubling like the General State of chaos
and craziness and you know we're trying
to do most of this mostly on our own we
do have some uh help with David's sister
who's been helping out and family coming
and going but like it's an awful awful
lot and uh but it's it's extremely
rewarding and tiring and great and crazy
and scary and wonderful uh Deep Thoughts
says are you still in support of Larry
Elder in any way I think Larry's message
is so important and needs to be heard
did we confirm Larry for next week is
that does that confirm yes well Larry
Elder is confirmed for the Reuben report
program next Monday if I'm not mistaken
so we'll probably get that up on on
Tuesday Larry is running for president
he I don't think he has the 40 000
unique donors yet to get into that
debate which is one of the reasons I
wanted to have him on quickly before I
get off the grid to help him get to the
40 000. I would love love love love just
to see Larry on that debate stage one
time get his ideas out there be great if
it doesn't happen it doesn't happen but
like I just I adore the guy we became
great friends which is which is such a
beautiful you know middle part of the
story of the guy that kind of woke me up
politically and you guys all know that
story for many years ago
um so I I certainly hope that he will he
will get involved and hopefully we can
get a couple donors going his way and
see what happens uh kavebz says hey Dave
uh when you want to check out from the
insanity enjoy a non-political podcast
what are your favorites obviously now
that you're a dad your checkout time is
much less yes well my checkout time is
basically non-existent
truly you don't listen to any podcasts I
don't you know I see clips of different
things like throughout Twitter from
Twitter on the during the day and that
kind of thing I watch the same things I
watched in 1989. I watched Seinfeld I
watch old episodes of The Simpsons and I
watch old episodes of The Golden Girls
that's pretty much it and then the other
thing that I do when I'm doing cardio I
watch old late 80s early 90s basketball
games that's it and I a lot of the games
I can remember literally every missed
shot every hit shot every rebound every
assist but I just love it it's a way of
escaping and uh and the last thing that
I need at the end of my day is just more
politics and all that Quinn says since
you've campaigned with Larry Elder and
Ron DeSantis what would you say the pros
and cons are between the two and what
did you learn about politics from those
events well it's interesting because you
know Larry and I campaigned together
during the the recall and
it was such an absolutely crazy time
because especially I did events with him
around the LA area so you got to
remember this is p covid Cali craziness
La particular brand of craziness so to
be out there with people and it felt
like Trump rallies so many great
Americans and flags and joy and
everyone's calling Larry a white
supremacist and I'm out there and all
these people white black otherwise gay
straight all cheering the guy on and it
was so fun and and it was just like it
was just like an endless party and it
was it was a long shot right it was a
lark it was like I don't know this thing
freaking happened but I I believe
I really believe if you're going to do
something you got to go all the way so I
believed I believed sometimes it's not
going to work and that's just what it is
but I think you have to if you want to
accomplish something you got to give it
your all and we I gave it my all Larry
gave it all IE did not agree with us and
Cali will I would say pay the
repercussions they're they're feeling
the repercussions of that right now but
it was just a great joy and I would say
on the DeSantis front um I've actually
only done one sort of specific campaign
with it uh thing with him once so far
which was Nevada a couple weeks ago and
I I freaking loved it like we were at
this Ranch about an hour outside Reno
there was like a mile long cars it's
very hot this time of year in Nevada
tell that to Joe Scarborough so it's you
know it's like 95 Sunny beating down on
us I'm burning up but we're we're on
stage we weren't on stage together I I
gave my talk first and then the governor
went on and uh and it was just great it
was this uh what do they call it the
Basque fry so they literally fry lamb
testicles that's the main food people
are eating throughout the day they also
did have chicken and the kids were there
and the people were there and I just
love for any of you that saw me there
and I know many viewers did it's like I
love being out there saying hi to
everybody seeing everybody people always
the thing is what AOC he doesn't realize
people mean online in real life they're
they're pretty great and what did I
learn about politics from those events
the main thing I learned from these
events is that people for the most part
at least the people who come to say
right-leaning events they really are
willing to disagree on a couple things
they love this country and they want to
figure a way out of the nonsense so some
of them may have religious beliefs that
might be different than how I live some
of them might feel differently on
foreign policy or whatever but it's like
they really do want to put that stuff
aside to to live a good life and save
this country all right we've got one
bone
question Deanna says what did you get
David for his birthday so it was David's
birthday yesterday which was very
exciting when we found out it was
national hot dog day he did not know
that his birthday fell on National Hot
Dog Day actually I really nailed nailed
nailed nailed the birthday present
I flew in uh his best girlfriend from
childhood from Junior High in high
school Megan I flew her in as a surprise
and it was so perfect because yesterday
at lunch she got here about 11 o'clock
we're doing the show and I told her come
in and we ordered lunch already I said
hide in the dining room and then I'll
bring out lunch and then you'll just
walk out when we sit down David walks
out for lunch and he's like and he sees
that lunch is just sitting on the table
and he's like he's like I really thought
you had a surprise for me I thought like
one of my friends was going to be here I
thought maybe Megan was going to be here
and she just opened the door and she's
right and he freaked he freaked out so
uh so then I cooked some some lamb for
us last night not lamb testicles regular
lamb chops without question and tonight
I'm sending them out uh just the two of
them to go enjoy themselves because
she's also got a young one at home so
it'll be good for them to kind of do
their thing anyway guys hope you enjoyed
the Q a and the show today if you have
not subscribed please do it rumble.com
Reuben report and as sensorious and
ridiculous as YouTube is uh probably
today or maybe tomorrow we're going to
cross that 2 million subscriber thing on
YouTube we have never put one of the
most proud things that I have related to
the sort of nuts and bolts of the show
we have never put a dime into
advertising on this show when you see
other big channels that do political
stuff like us they've many of them have
put hundreds of houses if not millions
of dollars into advertising to get
subscribers and all that stuff we have
done this all without one freaking dime
so get us to that if you're watching
right now and you have not subscribed
subscribed you might be our 2 million
subscriber you get nothing but maybe a
round of applause Connor could we give
them a pre-round of uh
pretty good pretty pretty good all right
post game show coming on the other side
reubenport.locals.com see everybody
tomorrow
oh
[Music]
foreign